I guess tonight's a very funny comedian
who hosts the SiriusXM Comedy Central
radio show you up with Nikki Glaser and
of course her hilarious stand-up special
bangin is streaming now on netflix
please welcome our really good friend
Nikki Glaser Nikki let's get started
right away
where are you I am in my dad's office in
st. Louis Missouri I have lived here not
in the office but I have lived at my in
my childhood home since since this
started honestly you the last time I was
on your show was the last time I did
anything you were the last person I
think I touched and it's true what Nikki
you were the last person I touched and
I'm married that's just a peek into my
life seriously it's we my parents and I
were just talking about it and they were
at your show with me they were out in LA
visiting me when this all went down it
was right before things got weird and my
mom just revealed to us a couple days
ago that she had been terrified that she
gave you coronavirus because you guys
hugged and it was still in that weird
phase of like do we touch but you you
hugged her and um and so she was
harboring this like deep fear and we
would we were watching your show every
night and she always has this like
awkwardness about when she's watching
when you clear your throat she's like on
edge like did I give it to him yeah so
she thinks she's out of the woods now so
yeah I think she's safe now
I remember your parents are very nice
people but I remember your mom licking
the side of my face long legs up both
sides and then she said you're a tasty
man and growl I thought she has issues
but I was very something because you are
always on the go and you your career is
red-hot you bet you were on a national
tour you have TV shows and the works and
then suddenly everything stops and this
is true for a lot of people yeah but
everything stops and suddenly on your
parents home
in st. Louis that's gotta be it's gonna
be like whiplash it just suddenly stops
for you it was um it's I never thought
this could happen in fact um I've lost
every job I had before this like they've
all kind of stopped or been put on hold
except one one show that I'm writing
right now that I pitched a year ago
which was a show in which I lose
everything because I get cancelled and I
have to move back home to st. Louis to
live with my parents and that's the only
show that is still like going through I
have to go through with so I'm currently
writing that show which used to be some
like kind of sci-fi thing like how could
that ever happen and I'm writing this
show now living here and it's uh um it's
weird cuz I'll write a scene and then
I'll go to get water in the kitchen and
like have just like an attitude with my
dad because I'm like an Act one you were
just such a jerk so it's just it was
never mind this would never have
happened for me to live at home with my
parents and it's um it's just hard
because I'm just used to going out every
night and doing stand-up I'm used to
just staying so busy and getting so much
attention and I've just I'm coping with
it I got a karaoke machine which I sing
karaoke in my parents living room every
day I sing about 8 to 12 songs a day
like what are you singing for example
I'm just peeling off and just sing it a
couple Taylor Swift songs maybe a
Britney Spears I've really been digging
into that that song lucky I've been
relating to it a lot cuz it's like it's
about a famous girl who cries at night
because nothing's working out her way
and it really it's just it's happening
if that's my song I'm gonna burn down my
gym pretty soon I'm just going full
Brittney I yeah I've been I've been just
trying to get my parents to film me so I
can put out content and remind people
I'm alive like in their disappointing me
they can't they can never get the right
angle and they're like we don't like to
film you so I've just been going to my
front porch and getting the security
camera to capture me yes you know it's
great we have the pictures we have the
pictures from your is this your ring
whispering app camera put these up it's
like you are going for it yeah I got a
remind people I need to find a husband
when I get out of here this is it's no
joke anymore I can't go through another
one of these even if they can you know
they say that it's gonna come back in
the fall even by then I want someone to
love me and and I need a partner I can't
live with my parents forever well I used
to be on the celebrity dating app Riya
yeah I've heard about that yeah so as
soon as I landed in st. Louis I powered
that up and was like what celebrities do
we have in st. Louis and there's one guy
who went to high school with Jon Hamm
and there's also a school with Jon Hamm
is a celebrity on Riya I'm kidding but
like literally there was no one in st.
Louis that was famous and so I just have
to yeah I have two results of going
through my old high school yearbooks
just to comb through and look for
potential mates or someone who could
sell me mushrooms now there's so many
people I'm thinking of like that like he
probably has a side gig been able to
meet up with anybody in like a socially
distant responsible way yeah I went on a
my ex-boyfriend just moved back to town
and so I'm like oh that's the next
chapter of this story I guess so let's
do that so I went on a hike with him
like a couple days ago we went on an air
I found it really good to walk in front
of someone who you're trying to kind of
impress because the whole time I was
just clenching my ass cheeks so I felt
like I got a better workout than I would
normally I really did I was like trying
to impress him from behind and then
later on I was like hey I'm sort it's
like oh you were trying so hard to win
him back with your but that was that was
good okay this gets me to what we have
to talk about because whenever you and I
chat it's a very segments are very
popular because you were quite candid
about your your dating life
yeah or I'm just gonna say a word I just
made up sex Beloit's
that's never been done before you you
were dating a lot before quarantine and
then suddenly what's it like for you now
it just stops yeah you can't you can't
do anything and no guys want to even
talk because you can't there's no end to
this there's no like eventually you're
gonna hang out I mean there's you can go
on social distance hikes but even that I
can't even go on I can't go see a guy I
I was recently talking to someone and I
asked my mom if I could and it just puts
them in jeopardy so I'm literally not
having sex now so that my mom doesn't
die which feels really heroic in a lot
of ways I'm like I can't go get in the
woods right now mom because I care about
your health and it just feels good to be
able to tell her that really you're
saying you're up there with the World
War two generation of heroism yeah it
right that's exactly because you really
I had to text a guy the other day I
can't go my mom and dad won't let me
which I've never I'm about to be 36 in a
month and I just texted I've never had
to text that before the last time I even
had to tell someone that texting didn't
exist
so that was truly the first time it's
just it's wild living at home I am it's
it's weird though because I'm and people
are like are you horny do you want to
get out there and the truth is I'm I'm
just not it's hard people keep asking me
like about you know if well I keep
asking myself why I'm not masturbating
more and it's because it's weird to do
when my parents aren't when my parents
are here you're in your you're in your
parents house I mean you know the walls
are thin yeah the dogs are small so they
go take the dog for a walk but they're
back in four minutes
it's not love time for me to get
anything done they're always here I
really I sent away for my vibrators I
really I thought maybe that was it it's
just like oh I need like some equipment
and so I had my assistant sent away for
them why did you send away for them
because I well I because I needed them
because I just I'm not good at manual I
just my hand is is worthless to me I and
I don't have a body pillow okay I think
you misunderstood I wasn't wondering why
you needed to masturbate of course right
okay yes because I'm a woman with needs
I'm told I don't believe it did I've
never experienced that myself oh yeah I
was on I was on the road when this all
went down I didn't have anything you
didn't have access to your equipment did
it it's all in my apartment in New York
so I had my assistant send it to me and
I only say that so that I can mention
that I have an assistant but she went
and she she I had to like tell her where
to go look for them I was like one of
them looks like an ear thermometer one
is like a massage chair
just send the chair I miss rubbing up on
that thing no she sent me this huge box
and I was like wrap it in weed so you
can hide the smell and she's for a
second all right yeah I'll keep a watch
everything looks good get those steps in
alright okay anyway
but I haven't even used him I like I I
told my mom I saw the box before I did
and she was like this is heavy what it
what's in here I was like candle sticks
like just me I don't making things up
and then the I don't I was just thinking
of something long and heavy and then
power went out the other issues that get
those candlesticks and I'm like well
they're not gonna work without power
those plugins they're electric candles
but even like yeah masturbating and in
your your house with your parents I
didn't do it in high school I wasn't
really a sexual like teenager so I
wasn't I wasn't doing it back then and
now I'm trying it now and it's just it's
I'm scared of making any noise I bite
down on a stick
like I'm giving birth in the woods that
come Pocahontas
yeah yeah can you mention that because I
was not a sexual teenager I became
sexual I think during Obama's first term
that's when I really blossomed are you
really a late bloomer
yes very late bloomer yeah yes so was i
I really didn't like boys until yeah I
was like 28 or something I just didn't I
didn't care and and so nothing about
living at home reminds me of like having
a sexual energy I really am reverting
back into being a teenager again I'm
listening to Taylor Swift in my bedroom
I'm borrowing my parents car I'm you
know but pretty soon my mom's gonna be
bathing me in the sink again it's just
it's a quick descent I've got to say
I've met your parents yeah
as you mentioned they came to the show
they they couldn't be nicer they seem
like very laid-back chill people they
watched you do your set which is always
very funny but also you know it's it's
something I wouldn't imagine most people
would want their parents around while
they're doing their set and then I saw
your parents afterwards they're like
wasn't she terrific and they're just you
know the most normal people in the world
they're great but are they laid-back
are they pretty chill is it I mean
they're they're okay having you around
obviously they must love it they they
love it we're having a great time I
really am like so grateful that they are
healthy and I get to have this time with
them and and it's it's just they're
they're cool I have cool parents also
known as alcoholics but they know I
don't I don't joke about their drinking
any more because they actually quit
talking to me and so like when I do that
but no they're super fun they're so cool
they um it we we we just we're having a
great time watching we watch you every
night it's like part of our ritual I
mean like we're big conan fans in this
house I'm literally sipping from this
right now yeah I have I mean maybe I
can't even show this because you guys
don't own the rights anymore but I have
my old tattered copy of in the year 2000
that
literally was in my nightstand in my my
childhood bedroom that I've notes in
this was my reign of comedy no that's
great looks like it's been through a lot
better than I am no you know I have to
say speaking of appearances you look
really good thanks you look very I don't
know you look very zen you look you look
very good you look thank you
are you because I think a lot of us I'll
speak for myself but you've been on my
show they paint a ton of makeup on me oh
my god I appear on camera I am really
doing like I'm not just saying this
like that's celebrity I'm not wearing
makeup I'm honestly not wearing anything
right now because it's a zoom and I just
thought started to think the first
couple zoom interviews I did I was
trying to put makeup on that doing who
cares and this I don't know I'm kind of
really liking not wearing makeup are you
liking that I love it so much I'm I was
gonna ask you about it like who's doing
your makeup now because it's something I
just it's you don't go on TV without
makeup I mean it's unheard of it's but I
love that we're getting back to it I
feel like a lot like the planet is
healing healing women's faces are like
getting back to their natural state like
a lot like the the Venice canals
dolphins are swimming in them now it's
like women have lines on their face I've
really I want to get in here and show
you some stuff that I got going I my
botox is completely gone like it's still
going right here but I got back this was
so smooth before and now it's like a
washboard I've been washing my intimates
in the sink on it which is really
helpful since laundromats are closed and
I also my eyebrows are I don't know if
you can see this but they're really long
I look like aids Vigoda I'm having
they're so so long and it just feels
good to look like it just to be my
natural seat again and thing is though I
do have I did my own makeup today I
really do have a lot on
when I wash my face later it's just
gonna run Brown looks like I'm living in
Flint Michigan it's the it's it's
ridiculous how much paint goes into
looking good and I haven't been wearing
makeup just in my daily life and it's
it's been great for my skin because it
is weird women are expected it's great
that we can cover up zits like it's nice
to be a woman and like what a guy is is
it you just have to have visit when we
can stuff an open wound with like dirt
clay and wonder why it keeps coming back
over and over so it is nice to get back
to her book I just the other day I was
um I was I haven't been wearing makeup
my dad really thinks like because
without makeup I look different my dad
thinks he his long-lost son returned
home he made of play catch and build a
deck I'm just a dad I'm a girl but the
other day I did put on makeup cuz I had
like a zoom call with some guy who's
rejected me in the past and so I put on
a little contour and some mascara
and I swear I went to the kitchen and my
dad kind of did a double-take it was
like you look beautiful and I was just
like see it's true like you like me
better with makeup like it's all it's
what's on the inside that counts and
he's like can you drink some makeup that
because you're not nice chug some
covergirl and there's my Corona yeah you
drink makeup you do not my parents well
I was gonna ask it's just like an
interesting area for me like you're back
home in st. Louis right and you are
you've just you've talked to me in the
past about how maybe you weren't
confident with guys or guys didn't
notice you back then now you're back
yeah and you've had all this success and
you're back in your hometown where you
grew up and you're interested in dating
or socially in distance yeah is there
are you trying to like look through like
guys that maybe didn't pay attention to
you oh yeah I got my yearbooks out for
sure high school but now it's sort of
its Nicki's revenge you've
come back yeah so what's that like
hi did I have I've been going through my
yearbooks and just kind of flipping
through seeing if I may be overlooked
someone trying to see with oh maybe this
guy what would he look like without acne
and maybe with some crow's feet and a
you know pill problem just classic st.
Louis and you know there I've been look
if they're all married you know for now
I think when this quarantine lets up
there's gonna be a lot of single guys
out there but it's really gonna kill it
yeah I can't wait but yeah there there
has been parts of me that want to go
back and be like would you consider me
now you know just to a guy in high
school
just be like hey doctor Havener remember
me I'm legal now just different
administrators he's like your to legal
yeah but it's just there's nowhere to go
there's nothing to do there's nowhere to
go with any of these people I'm just i
the it's weird how like my standards for
men have now changed I used to want a
guy that like was very handsome and
maybe you know successful a blue
checkmark on Instagram and now I'm just
looking for a guy with like a Costco
card and who could maybe work a crossbow
I just it's the other day I was at the
grocery store and the guy just bagging
my groceries I like got a little bit
turned on just because I'm just like
just a man just a straight a man other
than my dad I was like the way he like
bag to my cauliflower I was like he'd be
like a good dad like there's that's what
I'm starting if everything's changed for
me I'm glad I needed to like lower my
expectations I think yeah I mean that
was first of all that may be the guy for
you because you're you know it's you're
seeing a man in a good light when you're
seeing him bagging groceries he's he's
literally beating you he's putting
nutrition and food yeah you're paying
for it but in terms of like caveman
stuff it's sexy it's really seeing guys
be like safe and wear gloves and face
masks I'm just like in almost keeping
their distance from me
makes me like them more I'm like I'll
take a bandana to clean up on aisle
myself like it's it's pretty arousing
just to see guys having like basic
safety precautions now yeah it's it's
life has just changed so much I feel
like I'm just walking around my parents
house like I'm filming the first half of
a cymbalta ad you know before she asked
her doctor for help just like sweatpants
limp hair shivering like staring outside
of windows being like I used to have fun
like just things are just so different
now my spray tan is gone I don't I have
only just for the past 10 years of my
life just been reapplying spray tans I
don't know if you've ever done a spray
tan never have No it takes your white
privilege to a new level to be slightly
tanner but I'm back to like this is my
normal skin color and apparently I'm not
Guatemalan I didn't know that until it
came off I I didn't need a 23andme
report I just needed a loofah I guess it
should look great I think you look
really great
I think this is gonna be good for women
and for everyone just we're gonna remind
ourselves what it we look like again I'm
just getting away from beauty I mean I
got dolled up for this cuz it's TV and
it really matters to me but in terms of
just living my life I just I don't know
there's there's times where and I think
a lot of women are going through this I
just want to shave my head like I just
want to just just get I don't want to
have to care about anything anymore cuz
it's just about survival and then I was
like why do I want to shave my head when
I have it hasn't even occurred to me to
shave my legs even once during this like
maybe give those a whirl first it might
be weird to look like Sinead O'Connor up
here and Bob Ross down here but I've got
going on it's just it's such a weird
time my mom was telling me the other day
about my cousin is like she was like oh
he broke up with his girlfriend and you
know just finished school and I was just
like what's his story like I got like
almost interested in my cousin because
I'm so
just at least that's at least he's I
could see there's a way I could see him
maybe and convince my parents I need to
see my cousin and I didn't even occur to
me that he was my cousin and that was
inappropriate my first thought was like
oh no he's too young that was my first
real thought I out I was like oh he's so
cute
yeah yeah the young and and too young is
a thing because there I'm about to be 36
and I'm getting approached by a lot of
guys like younger dudes that are like
you could teach me a thing or two people
think I'm like very exceptionally
experienced and just this whole thing of
like teach me and I'm like algebra like
Ida what do you what do I get the
summers off I just I don't I need to be
taught still I know you know I did want
to ask you this which is you know I've
talked to you this is a good thing for
us to mention you and I have spoken so
many times over the years in person and
you know whether you did my podcast and
on the show so many times this zoom
situation oh yeah it is I'm doing a ton
of zoom everybody wants to zoom now and
it's this whole new world that I find
I'm getting a little this is fun but I
have so many people reaching out to me
saying let's zoom let's have a talk
about that on zoom and I don't know what
the etiquette is it's weird it's a big
screen it's not ideal I've been doing
stand-up on it and um it's just the
shows are they're fine um
and it is like I did say the other day
you know this wasn't as bad as I thought
it was gonna be and if the world doesn't
ever return to normal like I could see
myself like quitting because this isn't
good enough
the-the-the laughter lag when you tell a
joke in the two seconds you question
Everett you add those two seconds up and
you'll feel really bad about yourself
because you just I need the immediate
laughter what are you how are you doing
without immediate laughter I man I
notice that
whenever I'm passing my wife or one of
my kids and they're on a zoom call with
somebody I get in the background and
give me a little something and I see
them laughing yes yes it's sad I'm I'm
trying to get it where I can but I
notice it too I noticed that there's
this rhythm you can get into I mean
there's some stuff about it I like and I
know that you do you do this - you're
very funny in a situation where there's
not an audience and you're you
understand what's funny without meeting
an audience to tell you but getting last
this is fun you know it's it's fun and
so that's the part and there is a little
weird in zoom there's a little delay so
if I think of something funny I actually
way is it worth is it worth it because
there's gonna be a delay as opposed to
just saying it you know it's so much
riskier it really is changing comedy
it's making it a lot less satisfying to
do and I'm looking into other things I'm
like should I go back to school and be a
therapist because they seem to be like
really necessary right now I mean that's
the only people I'm talking to I'm just
it's not like I'm I'm it reminds me of
talking to boys in high school where I
would like crawl away to like get away
so I could whisper on the phone and now
it's just I'm talking to Donna about you
know how my mom had a weird tone with me
yesterday but I'm zooming I'm zooming
everything I am my favorite thing about
zoom and you got to do this when you
look when you're in your next zoom call
you've got to look for this moment cuz
it happens every time you sign off of
the call and you're like this was really
fun thank you so much okay guys we'll
follow up on that
thanks everyone have a great day okay
cool and then just after that call and
then the people looking for the Live
Meeting yes yes it takes about two
seconds and I literally like drool comes
out like no it's so it's so funny
because I'm noticing it
Izu with all these you know different
celebrities or all the different people
I talk to you
and I also zoom with
you know my producer and my writers and
but everybody's we all have this thing
that we do in society which is we have a
certain animated you know thing that we
have and then I love it because it takes
a second to find the button and so what
happens is it looks like people have had
a stroke so people signs but it's people
really are like you know Nicky it was so
great talking to you I love you you're
the best you know take care and I'll see
you and all this madness is over yeah
and then it kind of freezes there
because even after you hit it and you
stuck with that image and so you think
what person didn't give a [ __ ] about me
at all I just saw who they really what
they really think about me I see myself
to it so don't catch my face and like
that's the real you just you know before
quarantine I just thought that um I
don't know I've just had such a like a
busy life such I've worked so hard for
my career and and the feminist movement
taught me like you don't need to learn
how to cook you don't need to know how
to sew and that's like kind of all we
need to know how to do now and so I've
learned that I've kind of wasted my
skillset like I'm I'm a really do all
these women's sewing things I'm just
like wow they're so much more deserving
of love than me
it really has yeah to beat myself up
hate yourself more yeah during the
quarantine that's back in your parents
house hating yourself I am my mom told
me my roots need it I needed to touch
them up she was like those are your
roots look worse those are sad or roots
than the miniseries for God's sake good
joke that's a joke from 1977 I was like
good joke
dates me how do I even know about that
miniseries I've got sadder roots on the
miniseries that's fantastic I love that
it's look it up you'll learn a lot yeah
you really will yeah and I have it a lot
of people have been asking me if I've
heard my parents having sex and I was
just like dad stop I haven't and I have
a white noise machine do you want me to
hear what my mom if my mom screams
downstairs I just convinced myself she
won $20 on a scratcher
that's all three times in a row really
yeah that's that's what I do or she fell
out of bed I would prefer that she's
someone who plays the scratcher is that
what she does I I got her I got her a
bunch of scratcher tickets for Mother's
Day and she won 65 bucks baby she was so
excited my mom loves small amounts of
money she really gets psyched about it
I just then mowed her $50 actually
because she cleaned my bathroom for me I
like I can't I'd I got to this love I
worked hard so I would never have to
have to clean anything ever like it's
really one of the reasons that I wanted
to be like yeah baby is like I didn't I
don't like cleaning no one does but like
that was really a thing I don't like and
now my room is a mess and the other day
my mom was like please clean it and I
was like I'll pay you to clean it and
she's like you don't have to tell me
twice and she got in there and I was
watching her to like you know to see how
to tell her to do it better next time so
it was it was helpful because I can't
clean bathrooms
I can't the best I do is if that my
table will start to the water will start
to rise up to my ankles and I'll be like
oh this some I got to do something and
then I'll rub my foot in the drain and
swirl it around and pick up the hair and
then put it on the side with my foot on
the wall and then I'll leave it in there
until forever yeah I don't tell you this
but you're a bad person we all are deep
down we'll go on a walk in the woods
someday and I'll tell you all about my
thoughts on interviewing and I'll walk
ahead of you
and I'm better I'll flex an ass that is
completely non-existent now we have the
same ass I remember in high school I
watched your show and you referred to
your ass as a long back and I was like
finally I feel seen it was like seeing
someone with my same disability on TV
you proved to me that I could be someone
and nothing I do people say do this
exercise do that exercise no it's not
like I need to build up the muscles that
are there there's no muscle and no fat
there's a pelvic there's a pelvic a of a
pelvic area a rear pelvic area and it's
a straight drop it's a straight drop
rail little tiny man could safely leap
off my shoulders straight and not be
injured on the fall down they wouldn't
get they wouldn't anything on the way
down
Nikki I love talking to you you're
really fun always and I think this
situation you're in right now I I don't
like this pandemic I don't like this
coronavirus and quarantine but you at
home with your parents is a very funny
situation and it's cracking me up so
thanks Conan it's great stuff will come
of this
please tell them I said hello and to
stop making noise will they have sex and
let's make sure we do the face when I
yeah Conan I just want to say is amazing
to talk to you this is like the
highlight of my quarantine so far and I
love you it really is Nikki Glaser
banging is now available globally on
Netflix Nikki really good to talk to you
you too :